في روسيا ، يتم إطلاق وابل من اللوم
ذهابًا وإيابًا بين مسؤولين
سياسيين ومدونين عسكريين بارزين
على مقتل عشرات
الجنود الروس في ماكيفكا في
دونيتسك المحتلة الروسية ،
تعترف وزارة الدفاع الروسية بمقتل 89 جنديًا على الأقل
في القصف في
الساعات الأولى.  في يوم رأس السنة الجديدة لكن
الوزارة تقول إن السبب
هو أن الجنود كشفوا عن موقفهم من قبل
استخدام غير مصرح به لهواتفهم المحمولة.
يقول المدون العسكري الروسي البارز الذي يطلق
عليه اسم War Gonzo
إن مثل هذه المزاعم غير مقنعة في
محاولة لتشويه اللوم
تقول وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية إن ما
يصل إلى 400 جندي روسي قتلوا
في ذلك الهجوم
وجرح 300 آخرين ، لكن لا
يمكن التحقق من الادعاءات الروسية أو الأوكرانية بشكل
مستقل حيث يحتدم الجدل في
روسيا حول المزيد من الدلائل على أن
الهجوم الروسي المطول ضد
تعثر مدينة بقموت الشرقية رئيس
الشركة العسكرية الروسية الخاصة
يقول فاجنر ntractor أن أحد أسباب
توقف الهجوم هو أنه في
كلماته يوجد حصن في كل منزل ،
لكن القتال في بومود جاء
بثمن باهظ ، حيث قال رئيس
الإدارة العسكرية الإقليمية في دونيتسك
إن أكثر من 60 في المائة من
تم تدمير المدينة و 10 في المائة فقط
من السكان لا يزالون
أنا بن ويتمان أبلغت سي إن إن من
كروماتارسك في شرق أوكرانيا